today we're going to talk a lot about
Network graphs with a big focus on
visualizing them we're also going to be
talking a lot about people and what they
look like in data and how to make some
data for people uh because it turns out
I can't take the data from work and just
show it to you uh for some reason but
there's a lot of ways to get around that
and still get some really interesting
data I think that's a nice little uh
cherry on top for the session um great
so um starting off if you want to follow
along there's notebooks uh you can make
a code space you can uh run the code
along with us build out all the things
we're building and and learn a bit along
the way so uh included in the resources
on the link on the side here is this uh
homepage for the tutorial so it's
building an interactive Network graph to
understand communities uh and there's
some in uh info on like what we're doing
uh links to the different pieces and the
different libraries that we're going to
use all this is really just hosted in
GitHub uh so if you want to go to GitHub
you can see all the stuff here uh and
you'll see we'll start with like part
part zero and work through and there's
like little workbooks here as well as
readms uh and if you're sort of new to
this there's a couple ways to easily get
started one I think there's a link here
you can click launch and binder this
will spin up in a a Jupiter instance
jupyter Hub instance in binder and uh
install all the requirements to run this
uh if you don't like uh that you can
also run in a code space um so you can
click a button here or come up here to
code and like make a new code space in
GitHub uh which will spin up some
compute for you dynamically
load all the requirements and then
either launch with code spaces it's like
a either vs code or a you can do a
Jupiter space as well and then it'll
launch up a little version of that for
you great way to get started without uh
having to talk about it for more than
like 30 seconds or a minute however long
I've been ranting about this awesome uh
so that's the code that's the the main
topic uh and to start off I want to show
you a little bit of uh like a problem
statement a couple slides and then we'll
go through uh some of the tutorial and
start building out this thing but wanted
to motivate it a bit with like a a why
like why we're doing this okay uh great
so understanding people with network
graphs in Python um we're going to talk
about a couple different things first of
all who am I why am I talking to you so
my name's Lucas drand my pronouns are he
him and his um my background is I was
once a theoretical physicist uh really
focused in the computational side of
that um so did a little bit of work with
python and a couple other languages
mostly
simulating systems and then solving
differential equations numerically after
that I was looking for a little bit of a
change and I ended up joining uh this
company TD Securities which is a
toronto-based but Global um Investment
Banking wholesale banking uh operation
and uh worked as a quantitative
developer mostly doing what I was doing
as a physicist but now with Finance
instead of with dark matter particles um
it was it was almost as cool uh and more
recently also with TD Securities I've
been standing up our data science
practice uh with really a technology and
software engineering lens so really a
big focus on like how do we build tools
that are available to people easy to use
and really celebrate especially python
uh to do data uh workflows it might be a
shocker but things like python aren't
super uh popular in Banks uh and in a
lot of the like more Legacy driven
organizations so it's been a really fun
time over the last couple years uh
trying to bring that and change that um
as you can see in this this picture here
my instrument of choice is the saxophone
love music uh and python uh is
definitely language of choice I will
begrudgingly use other languages um but
python is really the one for me and
here's a fun photo from an inperson
python con um a couple years ago fun
okay so this is me hopefully uh you
didn't immediately drop off the call
after seeing that so so what's the
problem statement so something that
might be similar to you if you've joined
a big company or even just like a
moderately not well-managed company is
it's hard to find people know what
people are working on uh and and build a
network with people and really building
people and and networks is really key uh
to success so struggling to do that from
the start it can be a tough way to start
so problem statement is is like where
are my people who who are similar to me
at my very big company uh so be my first
day and I want to uh find other people
uh who probably know python maybe who
are working on projects that I'm working
on but it's my first day so I don't
really know what I'm working on um but
maybe have similar backgrounds in terms
of uh uh education maybe um or interests
other things that we can specify uh or
just in similar parts of their career
they they joined at a similar date to me
all those things would be useful to know
but it's usually hard so typically if we
look at something like a a reporting
structure we can get maybe like a
localized view um like I know who my
manager is hopefully I know who else is
on that direct team uh and I might know
the the whole hierarchy up until the CEO
right but uh that's not always the most
useful um especially it's hard to find
people who are without lots of clicking
or or navigation to find people who are
just a couple steps away from me if you
think of it as like a big family tree um
it's easy to see my direct family but
even cousins are are kind of a pain to
find in this way um without doing some
data scraping um um great uh but this
isn't enough so there's a couple reasons
why an approach like this doesn't answer
all the questions that we have um like
we mentioned same manager that's really
useful um theoretically we're working on
same the same kinds of things but not
always um another wrinkle is that
Regional teams can often have different
reporting structures so here we have
like an HR reporting structure where
that's not always the same as a project
or a team or a capability reporting
structure and so a common thing that
I've seen is that people in different uh
in different countries uh or just
different continents or different time
zones will have different reporting
structures and someone on my team
working on the same project just because
they like
d is that uh they might be 10 or so
steps away from me going all the way up
into the CEO and then back down through
another report structure to find them um
that makes it seem like we're not
related at all but you know we are we
work together another thing that might
happen is you might have your team
structure not in terms of HR reporting
um you might have it in terms of um job
families um sometimes people call them
like agile pods or like this is
potentially a more modern way of doing
things but you might be in a situation
where you and your family in this
reporting structure all have the same
job title um but it doesn't mean you're
working on the same projects um
potentially the opposite you could be a
pool of people who are like data
analysts all working in different areas
you have the commonality of having
potentially similar skill sets uh
potentially um similar kind of dayto
days but you you're missing now that
other piece that we were complaining
about but it's it's valuable as well
right um the last piece to point out is
that things like Niche roles um
especially in the data science and
analytics realm I see this a lot Niche
roles are often embedded and alone on
teams so someone will get like the data
scientist from some other group who will
come and be embedded in your team for
six months build something um but if
they're looking at this uh reporting
structure uh they're really out to lunch
in terms of finding similar people uh to
talk to really are working on different
kinds of things great um okay so a
couple of the key things we'll use um
when we're going through this and
building graphs in Python and
visualizing them um we'll need to know
like what are network graphs right
uh so a graph itself it's a math
structure there's objects inside of it
and different combinations of these
objects can be related to each other in
different ways so they can be connected
um they can be directional they can be
non-directional right um but really we
can think of these uh very vaguely as
like um Blobs of data that are connected
in some way that we Define um the actual
Blobs of data here are nodes um you
could call them like points or vertices
I like nodes uh and noes of attributes
um in in terms of the representation um
in the libraries that we use in Python
they'll have their own like
representation as an object and I think
most of the libraries use like C or rust
in order to uh Implement them um to be
more performant but you could think of
them as like a dictionary or or like
just a python object that has attributes
like a a class of some sort right um
finally there's edges in these provide
the relationship so edges connect two
different nodes together um potentially
two of the same node together um if you
have a a self- referencing Edge um and
like I mentioned they can be directed or
undirected so they can point in a
direction or they can just connect two
things together um so obvious like ways
to use pointed edges is like if somebody
like verbs something node verb node is
like I report to somebody um by
definition this is directional they
can't report back to me unless we're in
a very strange uh sort of company U but
we could EAS e also have non-directional
things uh just like being related by
some fact like both attended meeting or
uh both like python right that's
potentially an edge we won't do it that
way but that that's some some way that
you could use it right okay cool um so
we can actually just take all this data
pump it in and then visualize it um in
this case like this is a with some fake
data and we can visualize like a a
directed graph um we put people as nodes
so every node has like a person's name
in it um it also has a at least this
like who their manager is attribute we
can use that attribute in order to
connect the different nodes together so
now edges are this like manages feature
so um someone manages somebody
everywhere everywhere in the in the
graph all the way up to the top um so
already I think this is great um is
better than the sort of static page that
we had we can
see more than we could see before and we
can see people um that are at the same
kind of level in the organization um and
that are near to each other in terms of
uh reporting structure so it's a lot of
this was is off screen but uh we could
see that people like Christopher Johnson
reporting to David Chapman here reports
to somebody else off screen and then
repor into them is is Amy Todd and uh
Thomas yang right and so these are these
are like cousins in the family tree and
we can see them uh as being closer by
than somebody for Far Far Away right but
this is still just the the HR reporting
so how do we actually engage those other
attributes um there's some great
literature on it and we can look more at
it um I promise you we'll make something
a little prettier than this when we
actually build the code out um but one
of the solutions is to engage these
attributes and include them in the graph
so before we were drawing our graphs and
the graph is using just the data of
someone's name and their reporting
structure in order to draw uh and and
find their positions when we're
visualizing them and what we want to do
or an option to do here is to add the
other attributes in so here you can kind
of see there's people's names but then
there's also like these light blue blobs
nodes with uh languages so we have
typescript python Java JavaScript right
um we've also have some some dark blue
nodes here and one of them is UTC like a
time zone so now we're introducing these
trying to keep them
separate with some uh you know node
coloring and styling but we're starting
to introduce more data of different
kinds and then connecting those um the
idea here is that we can
uh we can take this information of these
relationships and then try to calculate
like a a distance metric or a nearness
metric for our nodes that we can see
that people uh are closer to each other
based on shared uh interests or shared
attributes outside of just the one
single attribute which is their HR
reporting
right um great um so there's we'll talk
a little bit more about that when we get
there but um a really simple way to do
this is to use um built-in functionality
of a lot of the network graph libraries
which is to do uh plotting and we can
plot the library using a force directed
layout uh basically what this does is we
set up um all of the nodes in our graph
uh as little balls and then we connect
them with springs which are the edges
and then we let a physics engine solve
this in order to push and pull the nodes
away from each other um pushing nodes
like to like push away from each other
but Springs like to pull them in
together and this allows the graph to
settle into an equilibri point where um
it has some sort of well it's
equilibrium point but it's found some
sort of minimum in its optimization and
and then it finds a point to settle into
uh sometimes it doesn't happen it's a
little funny to look at but uh a lot of
the time we can find that nice point and
then we'll have uh similar um nodes
pulled together by all of the different
Springs connecting attributes and
dissimilar ones pushed apart by the
natural uh alignment of the graph as we
visualize it so this is what our
approach is going to be a really simple
way to find close peers in an
organization um and yeah there's a
little link here uh if you want to jump
to it it's also on the side uh sideb if
you want to look at the sample app and
play around with it um but we're going
to be building it in the next uh hour
and a
bit great um just a note um for
inspiration if we Zoom way way way out
it might look a little bit more like
this um and really what we're interested
in and like this is a two-dimensional
representation so we're already adding
more than two Dimensions worth of data
and then trying to like squish it down
into a space which could be a little bit
diff difficult but um what we can kind
of see here or the takeaway is like
there clusterings and groupings of nodes
uh that are more prominent some of the
nodes are very much individuals and
outliers but the little clustering in
groups uh look like Prime candidates to
draw a circle around and then try to
name to say like ah those are the people
who know uip path scal and python I bet
they're data scientists right or these
folks know a lot of JavaScript and uh
Java like I bet they're traditional um
app developers right full stack
developers those are the kinds of tasks
we can do after we've drawn uh and
created this graph
great awesome so if you're following
along let's jump into it um so the first
thing we wanted to do is we want to work
with some actual people data
so a problem is people data is sensitive
um we can't just go and have people's
data uh not for this presentation at
least um and there's some ways around
that so what we really want to do is
create something that we can use in this
uh in this tutorial um to represent
people there's a couple features of it
that we already decided we cared about
that we thought uh we thought would be
useful so those pieces were um we need
need some like unique identifier names
are good uh we talked about um where
they are could be useful so like it
could be an office a location we talked
about maybe like time zone could be
useful uh if we're thinking of this
application as
being uh uh finding your peers or
finding people similar to you on your
first day of work uh or just you know it
doesn't have to be the first day of work
um so we probably want to find out
people with similar interests similar
locations maybe but maybe not we might
not want to always have that on um teams
or project focuses lines of business um
probably useful to know if someone's in
like sales versus data versus Tech
versus I don't know like uh um office
management I don't know all interesting
things um to be able to factor in um we
definitely need to have a field which is
a manager um so this is how we build the
the traditional reporting structure so
we still like that we need to have that
connectivity in there uh and then we
want to know programming languages maybe
like apps they've used over time um
maybe we're interested in their tenure
how long they've been with a company um
that could be helpful as well if you're
looking for like um you know this this
tool could be equally um let's match up
to new hires as it could be um let's
find a mentor for somebody right
um great um
or projects worked on great I think we
said all those things so how do we do
this it turns out there's a few ways to
do it um one is to use this great
Library called Faker so um check out the
docs um but the way figer works is you
import the library uh you create a fake
instance um we need to do this because
it's going to store for us some context
of things like what values have already
been used um the distributions of these
things
uh as well as allow us to customize this
if we wanted to um which we will um so
out of the box it has a a way to
view
um uh number of the built in options in
Faker um to build a profile for somebody
uh so all of these themselves are
separate um Faker um providers that can
generate things like username or names
or like locations and addresses right um
and it puts it all together for us
nicely so um this is good um we could
generate like 5,000 people like this
stick it into our graph and then go from
there um but out of the box it looks
like uh there's a lot of variability in
uh in uh the the results here so here
we've got like a job of an estate agent
and there's no estate agents in my
company uh that I was thinking of in my
brain I'm like a generic kind of tech
company um so like maybe that's an
outlier but I I think if we keep running
over this we'll find out that it really
is pulling from like a very large Corpus
of different uh results um also people
in uh giving residences all over the
place um we're getting their blood group
which we theoretically could use this
but I feel like that's probably too
personal um for the kind of information
we want I certainly don't have access to
that um and but you know like some
things are good like actual names is is
useful instead of calling somebody like
employee 123 um which is a not a great
name
um for somebody I wouldn't name my child
that
probably um great so what else can Faker
do um we're going to get some some lift
from using this fake object over
something like just like creating a list
of unique values and sampling it uh so
one thing we can do is get unique
versions of anything so I'm using the
fake uh instance here and I'm going to
say uh I could say uh rather fake prefix
right and it'll give me different
prefixes for people's names um that's
great um and it'll do it forever right
um with equal probability of pulling
them which is neat um but I can also ask
it to uh give me unique versions and
basically this is sampling with removal
and whenever I pick out one of the
values it's removed from the possible uh
list of values I can run this and
eventually it'll raise an exception um
because I've run out unique values now
this is a bad example because lots of
people share prefixes um but it takes a
lot longer to run out of unique names
and so I think you're with me I think
you're with me uh great so we can go
through all the unique ones and
eventually run out of them um and in
fact I've used this twice now and so
there's just none left um there are no
more unique prefixes because I've used
that up in the fake
object we sort of did this part before
but we can we can go in and uh generate
a couple people and look at them side by
side
um and uh you know just give it a go um
and see if this makes sense um but we
can generate three different people here
um maybe just
for sake of uh visibility we can just
look at the different jobs we kind of
went over this right um we can look at
five people four people we got an
advertising copywriter an exercise
physiologist cool charity fundraiser uh
engineer and uh oh sorry engineer comma
mining uh great
um yeah I think this is a great company
I I actually think this is neat we're
like making a magazine um or like
printing ads uh exercise is very
important to us uh one of the
co-founders is doing that uh charity
we're fundraising for that and then like
probably this engineer is doing a lot of
work um in the mining industry to pay
the bills but I think it's great um
right it's a little bit wonky uh we
probably want a way to reduce and in
Focus the scope of where we're getting
these values from into something that
makes more sense uh for for what we're
doing um
great cool so uh Faker provides
providers to do this um we can register
new ones uh we can tweak the ones that
already exist and this is essentially a
way to update their API which we've
decided we like we like being able to
use that unique feature and we like uh
that we just say fake this fake that and
we generate them conceptually I could
see us building a person
um who's you know
like dictionary of like uh you know job
equals fake job you know uh things like
that um and we can build out like a um
know Department equals fake department
so I like that as a as a structure and
uh we can build towards
that um someone in the chat likes fake
and I
agree Okay so one way to do that um very
easy way is to make a dynamic provider
with a dynamic provider we're defining
what the name of it should be um so here
we're going to be talking about like
potentially people here have different
um contracts with the company so they
could be full-time part-time or a
contractor right let's say those are the
options um so we're going to make a new
uh entry and Faker for that and uh it's
quite simple we create this Dynamic
provider
uh we give it the different options that
are available and then we can register
it with our instance um we do that here
and now whenever we call fake employment
uh we get one of these options uh that's
great
um and uh the way it works is the same
as the other um providers that we've
been using so far um where it has a big
list of possible values and then it's
sampling from that right um but in this
case what we're we're seeing I mean if
we did enough of them to be
statistically significant but you know
you'll have to bear with me a little bit
uh what we're seeing is that we're
getting equal times full-time part-time
and contract and that's not necessarily
typical of what we could have in a
company now there's a couple ways to
like mess around with that we wanted to
we could like um try to like add more
full times in here but it's not really
so basically we're like constructing a
larger distribution for us to sample
from that's weighted towards them but
there's more elegant ways to do that um
than just like making a really big list
um saturated with one value or two
values um great so we get a little more
low level with Faker as well we can dig
into uh base providers so not just
Dynamic which does a lot of the work for
you but we can uh build on the base
provider so here it looks pretty similar
we're still like building this uh um
employment status is like a our provider
class here um here it was just being
built by this Factory function um and
inside of it we're defining um the
different statuses we want and here I
put them in a little dictionary and it's
mapping to a proportion that we want to
be the the whole right um I don't think
this adds up to one but um turns out uh
we implemented it not needing that which
is cool uh so all we need to do is
create this class it needs to have a uh
um a function inside of it that
uh returns some value right so we are
taking care of the generation uh
generating results ourselves instead of
them writing this logic um so here we're
saying uh just return one uh of the
choices available so we're we're using
the built-in random
um module inside of fake so this lets us
use these like unique things later so
we're we're tapping into that as opposed
to uh using like the the class itself
outside of it um and we're telling it to
make some uh choices from the list that
we provided here and then we're giving
it weights for each one uh so this is a
you know one more step of complexity
here we're saying still we're sampling
from this distribution but we're going
to provide the uh we're going to provide
the um the weights for it right great so
now we can add that and now when we run
employment over and over again it should
be a lot more full times yeah and then
part-time contract popped up fulltime
full
time um we could also like make that
really obvious by putting into like
little Loop and like popping out a few
of them and you should see
roughly um you know seven of these were
full-time which is bang on and then the
contract ones filled out and none of the
part- timers showed up um which is you
know statistically very reasonable for
this small sample uh fantastic so we can
also do this and you could
imagine um we could extend that even
further uh and create more complex
relationships between things including
potentially generating more than one
field at a time if we want them to be
related or or dependent on each other um
as well as using um yeah if we wanted to
we could like enforce um distribution
samples um but generally as we're
sampling this with larger and larger
populations it should be
uh it should take care of that itself
great so um now we can think about what
we actually need for our person we know
how to use Faker um we've done a little
bit of magic with uh random choices from
lists uh so to try and Kickstart this um
one thing we can do is write down some
data classes that we want to fill out uh
I think this is a neat um not so new but
new feature uh in Python um to really
quickly create classes and objects where
we can store data uh in a specific
format so here we're saying uh this is
information we want to generate for
every person um we'll have uh a time
zone so here's an enumeration for a time
zone uh in this case there's only three
so uh feel free to like add some more in
um the format here is we can just add a
um like uh just the name of it and then
automatically generate the um value for
it because we don't really need that we
only really need the name if we're going
to refer to it this just makes it easier
more convenient in the future as we're
uh writing them down um then we can have
an actual location object it'll be a
city a time zone in a country um
probably we could automatically set the
time zone piece based on uh the city and
Country maybe not though um maybe that's
not a unique combination so maybe even
the three aren't a unique combination um
trying to think about some countries uh
who just like love to have the same city
everywhere
um uh okay so what does our person look
like our person will have a name they'll
have a date they were hired it'll be a
big time. dat great um they'll have a
status um so this will be full-time
part-time contract um we could
absolutely uh we could absolutely have
like another an for this or something
um we can have some like list of
languages they know manager team title
location right great um so now we can go
and create a person uh this person's
employee number one I know I promised
we'd have real names for people but this
is the exception um and we can have a
nice little um representation of who
they are this is great um I made a kind
of wonky helper function here because we
don't always want to have especially if
you're thinking of something like a
programming language somebody shouldn't
necessarily only know one two or three
programming languages it probably is
different depending on what part of the
businesses they're in or what their job
is also probably um they I don't know
they they and not everybody knows three
program languages right so it could be
different um plus it's just different
across
people at this point you could be asking
like why are
we guessing what these things are and
then trying to construct data that
vaguely looks like it um we could
probably just write down the different
distributions of things that we see and
all the relationships and then sample
from that that's definitely an approach
we could use um this is another way we
can do
it great
um cool so we could do the same thing
with programming languages that we did
above um we have different weights for
different languages and we're going to
use this choose a few um and it's going
to choose some number of programming
languages for somebody between one and
some number and uh oh between one and
all of them and it's going to
uh give lower weights the larger number
you get so we think a lot of people know
one or two or three very few people know
all of them but it's not impossible
right um cool so if we wanted to now we
could like get a fake uh Lang
programming
programming languages and that'll give
me like some number um great we can do
that Faker is becoming more powerful for
us and now we can make a person with the
name H higher date status languages but
I'm going to say with Team title and
location these are probably all related
together um so there's a couple ways we
can approach that but uh one way is just
to write everything down so here we can
construct a view of what our company
looks like here let's say that there's a
couple different kinds of uh teams in
the company um each of these teams have
different job titles inside of them the
different teams are in different offices
globally right and then
um I think that's it um so here we have
example devx has engineers and an AP uh
pretty simple sales team has Associates
and VP and then uh uh what is it like
support has analysts and managers like
there's some overlap of job titles um
and then similarly different places like
this company's in New York Toronto for
Lauderdale duin London Seattle um and
then different uh locations have
different teams um basically what we
want to do is for every person here
we're going to pick uh whatever the
topmost of these relationships are so
we're going to pick out um what is it
like a team do we pick a team first oh
we pick a city first because only
certain teams are in certain cities so
we pick a city and then from the
available teams in the city we pick a
team and then from uh the available
titles in the team we pick a title uh
and we didn't get smart and say like
there's only one VP per team but that's
something we could do um in this
function here uh this title City team we
can also um register this inside the uh
Faker uh instance if we wanted to um
that would be fun so here we have
someone in London uh Great Britain um
UTC time zone and they sales associate
right so this is nice um this is solving
the problem we had before with uh
people's like titles not really matching
their their department and things like
that so this is helpful and uh this is
going to be um making it easy for us to
create a person so now our person we can
update this and say like let's get the
title City team for the person um and
then if they're an engineer um we do
something what do we do with this maybe
nothing um but if you know that
someone's technical based on their title
we can start to give them different
features so in this case I think the
idea was uh they can know more
programming languages if they're
technical um but maybe we Max it out at
uh like um one if you're not technical
something to make the data look a little
more realistic right uh again something
we can get from sampling real data as
well but uh we don't have the real data
so uh great so we can look at this in a
data frame uh we can generate like 150
people um and they look like this they
have names dates statuses languages
teams titles and location we're just
missing manager so we don't know um who
manages who uh so in this case let's
just use something simple and a bit
janky in the code and let's try to pick
a manager for everyone who's already in
their team uh and who has uh an equal or
higher rank in terms of the like
different roles in the team so um we'll
just like find the maximum rank so we
can assign the ranks to different people
um by by doing a little bit of Panda's
magic here um but uh with a couple
different functions we can pipe this in
and pick out somebody who who satisfies
these conditions so we want the rank to
be as big as
possible um but we'll accept somebody
reporting to someone of the same title
uh if someone doesn't exist because it's
quite possible that we generated a whole
team with no VPS in them and what a
world that would be I've thought about
it a
lot um last piece is we actually need a
CEO so all the teams are terminating at
some like top person but they don't
report to anyone so we can just inject
one more person now we should have um
then assign everybody who has no manager
to this person and now we should have a
complete tree organization right um
great uh here I just like flattened out
the data frame a bit because uh location
was a little bit uh Troublesome later on
and now we split it out into like the
individual column City time zone country
um great so does this make sense um we
certainly did this and it seemed
reasonable at the
time but what does it look like um great
so we can do a quick little plot here
and take a look at um I mean we can cut
cut and paste it a couple different ways
so here we're looking at different
facets of the data so countries are
breaking up uh into chunks of this data
frame um so we we're seeing lots of
folks in the USA some in Great Britain
some in Canada some in Ireland in this
case uh and then we're also using Color
to break up the dimensionality into um
to the different teams that they're on
and so this should we should see teams
being localized right so in this case
like if we just look at the business
team uh they're in uh the USA Great
Britain Canada but not in Ireland I
think that was by our design uh
similarly if we looked at like uh just
the devops team they're only in Ireland
interesting um I I thought that they
were allowed to be in Fort Lauderdale or
something it was a long time ago that we
were doing that um and then we can start
to also see distributions of uh the the
roles in different teams so if we look
looked at
um yeah in devops there's like a a kind
of flat distribution of engineer senior
engineer manager there's not a lot of
them to really make this assumption
there's a lot of senior managers so um
why are there so many senior managers I
don't know um but if we looked at uh the
do the product team have Engineers uh
yeah product team it's also kind of flat
um I think what we're seeing is that we
we kind of uh designed it this way um
that there's an equal chance of pulling
those differen things um cool um and we
can get a bit of like a a quick highle
view of this um great
um great so does this look like a
company um I'm not really sure it's hard
to say because we're not seeing any of
the reporting structure piece that we'd
look at before uh we're not seeing
really like how these teams are grouped
together we can we can definitely spend
lots of time here and try to think of
smart ways to slice and dice the data
and look at it flat here and try to make
uh I don't know intuitions about whether
this is representative of a real company
um but I think it's better to look at it
in a graph that's why we're here okay so
we can actually make graphs now um and
if you're wondering there's another
Library that's great for this um it does
not make fake data like this um instead
uh it makes synthetic data from real
data so the idea is it's not just Gan
based but uh the idea is that it'll
train um train a model on your real data
and then it will generate data
that has none of the uh sensitive
Natures of the original data it is
unique and new data uh but it retains
the statistical uh features of the old
data and so this is a great option um
and Y data and synthetic is one of the
option options that I've used before and
has worked great um but you can do this
yourself if you really want to like
train Gans or you know work with a
couple different uh I don't know couple
different uh models to do that uh it's
an option um but uh yeah so a cool um
additional piece to do if you're
following along is like you could check
out synthetic data and like take the
data we already generated here uh and
then run that through the synthetic data
and see if it's kind of similarish
looking but with like new names for
everybody new team names um depending on
how much you put into it in terms of uh
like what data to change it'll be quite
interesting great okay so now we have
data uh we have we have real people well
real fake people data and we think it
looks pretty good um okay so now we can
jump to the next section of this um
perfect so um let's get this into a
network and visualize it so first off
we're going to be using
networkx um it's a great library for
creating manipulating generally studying
and uh implementing more like more
complex uh graph analyses and python um
it's in memory and it's fast uh so
sometimes some places this will break is
when you have very very large networks
um typically in my experience it's
worked for pretty sizable things um
where I see more breaks happening is on
the visualization side like
visualization libraries struggle to put
uh tens or hundreds of thousands of dots
on the screen but like the network is
fine putting tens or hundreds of
thousands of uh nodes into a you know
into memory that's that that's fine so
um typically though there's a couple
approaches where you Shard or use other
libraries that'll do that break your
compute across uh multiple nodes compute
nodes rather um but you know that's
pretty typical of of anything that's
starting to break from being the
inmemory approach awesome so Network X
we can create a graph uh it is very easy
to add nodes to graph uh there's a
method add node we can give the node it
needs to have like a unique identifier
here uh I think maybe this will be
helpful to pull up um so here we can
like the ad node takes a unique
identifier um and we refer to it by that
that's it's like ID we can also assign
other attributes to the node as we make
them so we can say like add a node me
it's a type person and now person is
going to be an attribute or type is
going to be an attribute um with the
value being person and we can uh pass in
really any objects to it um it'll
complain later if things aren't Json
serializable if you try to do other oper
operations with it um but um mostly
moving the graph into other libraries to
do things like visualization but uh you
know just something to consider but yeah
we can also put in like a list of values
so here we have languages and it's list
but one one element it's python great so
I have my graph I have me in it um we
can also add things from iterables so
here this is a this is
a of TPL um and uh we're adding in new
and uh we can so uh specify instead of
being a keyword args we can put in just
a dictionary um to map it in and here
we're saying languages python Scala
python JavaScript cool um and both of
them we're labeling as type person so we
can add in iterable and populate the
graph and also add attributes to all of
them as they're added in
fantastic um don't add it too many
times um we can look at the nodes um if
we just call nodes we can look at the no
IDs uh so that's great we can also pass
in data uh and if we say data equals
true it'll give us back that whole
object it took us a while to get here
but now we are looking at um this
underlying structure represented as a
dictionary here so you can see like here
is that node me that I created and it
does really just look like a a python
object um represented here under the
hood this is a little dictionary in the
representation great so all that
information is in there
um and what's neat about just this
accessing and setting piece of network
graphs is that it's easy for us to pull
out just the pieces that we need as well
as to iterate over them so it's going to
make some of the tasks later on um a lot
simpler so here for example I can just
see everybody's uh programming languages
uh similarly I could I could swap this
out and say um everybody's type I guess
but that's all the information we put in
here uh so we have programming languages
and this is like a node data View
um what's neat about it is it's uh
iterable as well so
um do X for X in
this yeah so then we can pull out little
things um including we could just like
go over the values for
things or pull them out as like little
dictionaries in a mapping great so what
do we do next uh we have nodes we also
need edges so now we can connect
different nodes based on their IDs and
then label them we can also add
additional attributes
like anything equals one like we can add
these things in so here I'm adding uh I
added too many there but um I added
edges from me to you um and the label
this like the type of edge this is is
friends which is really nice um and then
you and them are also uh connected by
friends so that's great we can do a
graph-based
uh math here and so there's a whole I
mean we're not going to do much of it uh
in this tutorial because we're focusing
on the visualization side but there's a
whole wealth of U things you can do with
graphs that are in the documentation
including things like uh neighborhood
detection or um finding influential
nodes in the graph so like things that
are most connected but also things that
can be um important while not being most
connected um so there's some algorithms
to do that they're very popular in
Social Network graph analysis
um which is kind of what we're doing and
would be useful thing um in this but
we're just focused on the visualization
side great so what's one of these things
what's the shortest path from me to them
um and it gives it's like me you them um
we go through you to get to them um you
know we value you but you're also
connected to them and we're interested
in them um and we can print all those
out as well all the different uh
interconnections between things so it's
like me and you are connected on along
friends um you and me are connected
right them and and you are connected um
but me and them are not connected right
we're not adjacent directly great so um
networx networx itself has a
visualization uh function so we can just
draw this and we could end here but I
don't I think we can do better um so
here Network X Network X is using
matplot lib under the hood um it's
taking all the nodes that we have the
edges and it's generating positions for
them um so it it does that using uh
there's some like different layouts um
if you're
interested um like one is a spring
layout and I can just generate this and
it gives me an array of XY coordinates
and that's what's being plotted right
now it's doing the same for the
edges um and it's doing this a physics
solver in the back end that we talked
about before great um so let's actually
try this with our data let's plug it in
and take a look at it uh so here I'm
just running that old notebook and it's
going to go through and print out all
the stuff that it printed out before uh
because it was a little lazy and uh now
we should be up to speed with all the
functions we created in the last one um
if it gets janky that's why definitely
that's why okay uh now we're ready to
populate our Network rout so we need to
take the data from that data frame that
we created at the end of the the last
piece or from the list of those people
person
objects and we need to um push those
into the graph
okay um so I'm a big fan of this more
iter tools Library uh it implements a
lot of the recipes from the iner tools
built-in Library um and it makes these
like really common things you might be
using more than you think uh easier and
easier to do um for example take we'll
take uh the first and items of an
iterable as a list useful um instead of
using like some slicing and then
like colon n um I mean it's simple but
it works on uh um iterable objects as
well like generators as well cool so we
create our graph it's empty and then
we're going to add nodes into it um we
can use that add nodes from it iterable
and in this case we're going from our
data frame um we're making into a
dictionary make it easier to iterate
over we could have done this part
differently uh We're looping through it
and we're pulling out um the object type
that we want for uh the graph which is
we want to have an ID followed by the
attributes so here we're using the
person's name as the ID and then we're
using that whole node uh representation
which is like a big dictionary as the
person um we're also setting some more
um attributes on on this for everyone so
we're setting person equals true which
seems useful if we're going to add
different kinds of attributes in the
future uh we're also s setting type
equals person because whoever made this
tutorial uh got mixed up halfway through
and started using type instead of the
person Boolean and that person was me uh
great uh and finally we can take uh
three nodes from this and just print
them
out uh
great so
here um we can see a couple people so
who are these people we have James
Roberts they're a person that's great um
they have a name a higher date a status
right they know some languages this is
the data we had before and now it's into
our graph um that's what we're taking
away from this so now we have all those
nodes excuse me and uh probably we can
visualize it so we have that great draw
function it just works right and we can
print it so uh this is is it these are
our nodes um we could probably try it
with the names too um but you know most
notably um well that's not really
helpful but most notably we don't have
the edges nothing's connected it's also
just hard to see any differentiation
between people I mean the having all the
names glump together doesn't really help
but uh something we can do uh inside
of uh Network X is draw is we can add
some coloring to the different notes uh
so let's add some color so let's try to
color them by team and then see how the
different teams line up um so here we
were using
umly before and so I'm going to just
take one of their color uh pallets so
there's some like great color pallets
inside of it and it's just a list of
different colors
um this one is meant for qualitative
analysis so it's they're generally used
used for categorically different things
and so the colors are distinctly
different in color um if you're picking
a different uh color scale just keep
that in mind if you pick something like
diverging um
or there's a couple different names of
things but things like uh that are meant
to be like if you think of like heat
Maps or like different gradients of a
single color it makes it really hard to
differentiate I mean even using colors
to differentiate is is a little bit uh
ke but it's like one of the dimensions
we have access to here
great so here we can uh take that list
of colors and we can map it against the
unique uh Team values um from our data
frame and we can get a mapping from um
the team to a color so basically we want
to go in and color those nodes with this
um networkx doesn't like RGB though it
wants to have a hex value uh so we can
do some math uh that definitely came
from chat GPT uh to convert these into
hex codes um using some super FST string
magic great now we have a function to
generate that and lo and beh lo and
behold it appears as if we have
different nodes with different colors
from different teams right that's great
we do like that um cool this still
doesn't very much make sense um we don't
have the key thing of our graph here
which is the edges connecting them
together so let's add those
in let's add those
in um great so this is
uh lots of ways to do this right we need
to generate some iterable here that's
going to connect each of our different
nodes to uh the other node based on one
of the attributes in the data set so we
can make use here of some of the pieces
that we highlighted before and how
graphs work um if we look at our graph
nodes um and just look at the manager um
attribute this is actually giving us uh
if you look at it it's like a dictionary
I mean it's a mapping here from a node
to the manager and this is exactly what
we need in order to know like we want to
connect this node to this node so um
fantastically this is is giving it to us
um I mean it's not free but it's a c so
it's basically free um
lovely so that's going to be our
iterable just that's itself um we can
add edges from that iterable um if
you're thinking like oh why not just why
manager why not other things too that's
what we're going to do uh and we'll do
the same great thing here where we add a
manager as label and manager also true
great and hopefully I only ran that once
and when we draw it it should look a
little more like a real thing and we
should be a little bit excited about
this although it is still hard to read
them there's no Legend which is fine um
but what we're seeing now is some
structures start to uh form in in the
physical space of the visualization uh
so whatever the yellow was um this is
like all one team um so kind of
strangely it looks like two people from
the yellow team report in to one to the
and then I mean it's kind of hard right
but maybe one directly into the CEO um
but it looks like teams have their own
sub reporting structure and this is what
we defined before we said that teams
should all report everyone's manager
should be on their team except for the
team lead who reports to the CEO so it
appears as if this is working
um right and sorry I thought about this
for eight more seconds and uh in this
case these two yellow people are
probably uh they're of equal level the
two like this fella and the one at the
top of the other big bunch of yellow um
and that's great so this looks vaguely
like what a company could look like um
and we're on the right track um so
structurally we're okay but we want to
analyze more about what the values are
inside the attributes so we want to be
able to interactively
um learn more about this um
no oh great um so there's a couple ways
we can do that so there are other
visualization libraries in Python that
allow us to interact with data
um one such option um is
plotly so this wraps a JavaScript
library um similar to how
like um bouquet or Al um other um yeah
I'm blanking on the others but uh they
have similar interfaces and we can
generate nice interactive graphs so um
here's some helper functions basically
what we want to be able to do is
dynamically generate a scatter plot so
we want to draw all the nodes of our
graph out as points
right we want to be able to color those
points or size those points in a similar
way that you would with a normal scatter
plot in in plotly um it follows a little
bit the grammar of Graphics approach to
plotting and so basically that means
that when we're saying plot this um we
say uh we can pass in different
arguments to say to control how it
visualizes itself based on the actual
attributes in the data so you you
typically you do this like color the
points based on the value in this column
or like make the size of the points the
value in this column things like that um
great so what did I say we're doing here
um the the bulk of the work here is
we're making a scatter plot um we've
generated X and Y coordinates for the
points based on a layout um that we've
generated as well so we saw the layout
before this is going to give us XY
coordinates we're setting that as the XY
for the plots uh for the
points um then we're going to update
that with a couple different uh I don't
know fun layout things I think
contextual help is getting mad at me
here great once we have the nodes for
the graph um which is going to be a
figure here we're going to add the edges
um it's optional in this so there's like
a flag to turn it on and
off drawing all the edges
is a bit or rendering all of the edges
is uh computationally expensive and you
might have to wait
um many seconds for it to uh render
which is a little annoying but uh then
we're just doing that same thing where
we're going through the list of the
edges and we're connecting them if they
need to be connected
great um cool so now we can take a look
at that same layout of
data um and we can hover over and get
more information about the points so
like here we saw these purple points
they should be colored by their team and
so we can see like digging into this
this is the devops team um they have
very ious different uh ranks um based on
their yeah let's do this with the edes
stre um so we can go and explore a bit
and do more of our like highle check
here to see like does this make sense as
a as a graph
um and uh who are these purple people
like um they they appear to
be not the devops team and so oh sorry
we colored this by uh the country
they're in so purple people are in
Ireland uh great and so different teams
but the teams we expect um also the
reporting structure seems to have people
closer to the center okay yeah here it
is um so we have the CEO in the
center and then uh for example here
someone that reports into them is uh
what is their job here they're a manager
and then folks they have a manager
reporting to them and then uh Engineers
senior Engineers reporting to them so
this follows what we wanted to kind of
get and now we have a little bit more
ability to interact with the plot uh we
could I don't know like really zoom in
or something if we wanted
to uh as well as uh like highlight
different pieces um so we've taken that
structure um we've boiled it down into
something that most plotting Li
libraries understand which is XY
coordinates and then we've been able to
leverage this interactiveness of the
plotly
library but there's other ways to do
this um oops hit it again
uh so um there are some libraries that
are specialized for doing visualization
of uh Network graphs um one such is um
pis which wraps the viz
Library uh JavaScript library so here we
can actually just pass in our graph
directly um and we can visualize the
points so here if we a bit smart about
what the attribute names are it'll
visualize and let us interact with this
there's no hovering uh capability except
for like a single term here um but it
does allow us to do uh the thing that
maybe a lot of people have come here
today for which is H grab nodes and drag
them around um which is pretty exciting
um so if this is why you're here this is
The Notebook you want to open and drag
stuff around um so this is great um as a
kind of note here uh the the library
takes a little while to load once you
you create the once you tell it to like
render the document it is doing uh in
this case we do not pass in XY
coordinates so this is not a
static um static plot so complaint uh
number one about doing this with plotly
all these points are static right
they're they are where we plotted them
um depending on how you do it as well
like you could maybe complain that
there's some overlapping to these points
based on the zoom level like you could
you could complain about that um but in
this case it's actually doing the
physics solving life and when I move
points around it it continues to do
physic solving you'll see like I'm I'm
like pushing these nodes away and so
this will break down if you add
thousands and thousands of nodes in a
lot faster than something where we've
like pre-computed it and then don't
allow it to to change okay um there's a
couple magic uh Magic values uh for
attributes that will cause the
library to plot differently so one is
group um this will control how coloring
is happening of the
points um I believe we can also specify
what the colors are for the different
groups separately title is what the
hover text is that's when I actually
hover over here in this case it appears
as if I mean maybe confusingly we
already had an attribute called title
and it was like job title and now
because it was called title it's being
used for the title um which you know
like very clever of the creator of this
to uh conflate all these ideas together
um and not the creator of the library me
just to be clear um okay the label uh is
displayed under the noes that's what
we're seeing when we zoom in which is
like people's names it's a little bit
tough to see uh in dark mode but I I
don't think it's worth switching around
right now um great so what we can do
here uh to make this a little more
Dynamic and a little more grammar of
Graphics e like we had going with plotly
um to make make this part of our toolkit
for exploring graphs um is we can make a
copy of our object here and we can
rename title to something else so then
it's not um you know like sitting on top
of that reserved name um and we can do
uh basically the same thing for all the
different attributes we want so um we
can make this function um and it'll take
in a graph and we'll give it um
different values for the different
things we want like should there be a
legend we we kind of hack that around
later how should the sizes of the nodes
be like should there should that be Siz
based on an attribute in the node object
itself what the label title and color
should be um and then we just go in here
and set those inside the the object
itself based on um the the column name
or the attribute name that may or may
not be passed in right um great and then
we can um build the network um using
graph uh gravis and then we can show it
right and then return that
um and this is a kind of hack together
um there isn't a legend functionality
for it um the way it works is here is
we're just going to like make other
nodes that
are on the graph and then those nodes
will be colored the same way you'll see
in a couple seconds as it uh and sorry
this is pis not gravis um gravis is next
uh great so now things are colored based
on um these things so this is like the
team name I think uh yeah that's what we
put in here so color is team we're still
labeling by people's titles uh but the
hover thing is the city that they're in
and then um we said make it black
background color to make it hard to read
um and so now we have colors for things
so this makes it a lot easier to do our
we're basically getting a lot of what
we're doing um with plotly except for
maybe less interactive hovering and um
hovering support right and we don't have
that like nice way to filter based on
the Legend um maybe things that we'll
want to build out later on um so great
now we can look and see uh we have folks
in Seattle um Toronto um but these are
all uh this this pink team which I think
is uh internal tools um and so they're
building internal tools lots of
Engineers senior Engineers uh VP and
then we see the VP reports into another
VP who has their own team of senior
Engineers managers VPS right and they
report into our CEO um who uh has a self
referential reporting I think they
report to themselves um instead of the
board or something we had to stop
somewhere I'm sorry um anyways great uh
so we have this structure it vaguely
looks like what we're going for here uh
and we can explore the colors uh so we
can start to use more dimensionality in
how we're plotting great uh so what's
another option here so this one isn't as
fleshed out um but another option uh
with a bit of a newer library is with
gravis so this actually wraps um the
same back end as piz which is viz but it
gives you other options as well um D3 or
um a three-dimensional plotting uh
Library as well um so in theory we could
build this out to have that same sort of
um um what's it called that interface
right we had that nice python interface
and uh we could uh make it so it's
easier to color different things um this
one doesn't seem to be finding an
equilibrium point so well it's like
still moving but uh we can still do our
dragging which we like um and in theory
there's a hover and a way to color these
as well it's just not implemented just
right here um but this is a a nice easy
and you'll notice it's it's a lot
quicker to
load um but uh this is
another I guess quicker to load but it's
not uh it's still stuck in the first few
iterations of solving but that's fine
um oh we hired a dentist as well that's
great um I haven't seen that pop up and
I've done this a number of times uh DDS
so you know Doctor of Dental Surgery fun
um so yeah what what other things can we
use okay we can also use D3 to visualize
it um it just takes in the graph uh
object as an
input um which is great and we'll want
to customize that with a lot of
different uh attributes so if we wanted
to make this nice and easy to use we'll
have to figure out how all these things
work and map that back into just what we
need okay cool um but great D3 also does
a great job of visualizing this and we
get some of that draggy droppy and the
other neat one um which is neat for
exploration but maybe less neat for
showing off is we can also plot this in
three
dimensions um so before we were losing
some of the meaning of the data perhaps
the interpretability of the data by
putting it into into two Dimensions so
the we we're taking information about
the relationships and relative positions
in the graph of of data and we're
condensing that down into something
visual in two Dimensions um we could
also condense that down into something
visual in three dimensions um and this
is what it looks like so we can drag
around um to to explore this
three-dimensional object um this is
really really interesting for more
complicated pieces especially as we
start building out more attributes that
we want to include in the graph right um
but it's not fantastic for well one it
requires you to to actually physically
interact with it as opposed to something
which has value just as a static uh plot
that you can look at right um like
zooming in here is great and like
looking at pieces uh but there is value
to having that um already baked in like
that anyways I think they go well
together and you can explore uh and
investigate the relationships between
people uh and uh see you know maybe it's
a little easier to find the CEO here in
the center but these are uh an
interesting newer Library uh with a
couple different options for plotting
depending on what you want to do great
um oh yeah other approaches to this um
probably what we want to
do is not hold ourselves to just two or
three dimensions and not only use a
physics solver in order to um to reduce
this down so like common approaches to
this is we probably want to like take
these nodes put them into a vector space
in higher Dimension so not just two or
three dimensions and then use a
dimensionality reduction and
visualization uh algorithm like TSN um
in order to take that and put it back
into two Dimensions but in order to best
still
represent excuse me the relationships
between uh the different um nodes
fantastic okay um I want to speed up a
bit um and sort of Zoom through this
next
piece um basically what we we left off
with is we have our graph
nodes um here here they all are spitting
out here but what we don't have is
uh we don't
have hold on I think we left the
some of
this comment out the piece that takes a
long time to run so we don't have to sit
here and
wait in the future great uh so we have
our attributes right we remember this
they're
connected um we're connecting by the
management but we want to add more of
these nodes in okay so we have all the
building blocks to do that basically
what we want to do is write a little
helper function here um in order to add
nodes based on unique attributes so this
is going to go into our graph it's going
to find all the unique
attributes um and so this is creating
uh yeah we're going to make a set of uh
all of the unique attributes for a given
one so we say like pick City we'll get
that set of unique cities and then we go
through that set and we add a node for
each one uh we also flag them right so
here we're going to add in all of the
different cities as their own node with
their own flag um another way to do this
that we don't address here is you can
instead of using um like a standard
graph like we're doing here you can use
a bipartite um graph and so you can
store these attributes in like a
different context within the graph as
opposed to them being uh right now the
only way we're differentiating them is
with these flags like the internal
attributes um but if we wanted to we
could store them as a different uh like
in a different layer of the graph you
can think of it and that can help us to
visualize them later without them like
interacting as much in the or have
different rules for how they're
visualized um but for this it does work
and uh we're going to sort of take them
all at the same uh level great
um okay so we have our helpful function
we can add in the different nodes for
languages for cities uh and for time
zones um great uh and it's easy for us
to use this function in the future to
dynamically add just what we want um
that's a point we want to get
to next we want to add those edges so
this is the same approach we took before
um here there's uh another like feature
of network AES we can give it a filter
criteria and get just like a subset of
the nodes in the graph so that's what
the subgraph view
does uh let's pull this back
up that's what the subgraph view does
here and this allows us to filter down
to just people in the graph so we want
to look at all the people nodes and then
we want to get all of the the mappings
from the attribute we provide which is
whatever we provide in the function uh
we want to Loop through these and we
want to add edges from the name to that
attribute for everyone who has that
attribute right um great this is a kind
of a generalization of what we were
doing before uh and it's going to mean
that we can say go back into my graph G
that now includes uh attributes um nodes
for languages and make edges to connect
all the people have a language to the
node of that language great um fantastic
we can plot that and take a look at it
um basically all we see here is we
should have some new noes like there's
new load nodes for just languages that
are scattered around here um along with
all the people and that the people
should be connected to them too
um great um I guess we could look at
that with like a threedimensional plot
if we were like really feeling excited
right
now uh and this probably won't resolve
very well but uh so we should be able to
like explore and see like people
starting to group up into different
regions based on uh like here's PST like
the time zone um and it's close to
Seattle which is uh like this is a very
good confirmation of our vague intuition
about how this works like Seattle is in
uh Pacific Standard Time and so we would
think that people the two nodes
themselves aren't
connected uh right they're not connected
but everybody who is connected to one of
those two nodes is also connected to the
other and so naturally they're being
pulled together this is really the the a
good indication uh of like what is
happening here um similarly right like
uh in our data set I don't I think maybe
um two different cities are both in the
same time zones there's a lot of overlap
there it's not like the most useful
metric but um in terms of us building
this intuition I think it's really
helpful uh
great um so yeah what else can we do
here um we've added in all these
attributes into the graph we can
actually
do uh a lot of graph analysis now
without visualizing right and so uh one
way to do that is to make an ego graph
it's centered around somebody or one
node in the graph and we can look at all
the other points that are within some
radius so the radius itself is like the
number of steps uh so we can look at
anyone who's connected within one step
of you which is in this case um managers
right anyone you manage or that manages
you and then the attributes like
language like python right um the next
step away from that is your manager's
manager right but it's also anybody who
uses the same language as you so we
could use this um as a way to look at
people who are similar to you basically
it would allow you to um to find people
like with the most number of similar
connections to you um which is
definitely interesting and it would
definitely be a great part of this the
only downside to that and what we're
losing is that we don't have the context
of like what things are similar so what
we just saw here with PST and uh Seattle
being similar nodes or like here uh yeah
Seattle and PST being similar nodes
sorry this is like unruly at best um is
that uh that they actually aren't
necessarily um you know they're equally
far away from you and far away from each
each other um in the graph um they're
both connected only through you uh in
this graph and everyone else who shares
those things and so we're losing that
context of like natural clusterings that
are happening that might have more
meaning than just the uh sort of like
naive um distan less approach to things
which is fine um there's other ways to
accomplish that as well um if you look
at especially the neighborhood section
of uh um the network X Library great uh
here's another way to do it where we go
and make that spring layout and then we
just do like a pretty simple ukian
distance between all the points and you
find people that are within your area so
this is basically the same approach as
plotting it and then drawing a circle uh
and saying like that's they're all close
to me right so we're getting some of
that magic uh from actually plotting it
and from the physics uh and then we are
um we're reaping that great um cool so
yeah check out some extras if you want
to have homework after this I guess um
perfect um I think this is the old
one
great so um we have all the pieces we
want now um oh maybe maybe we
don't come back to the main plot here um
right so yeah that's what we were seeing
here we we have a way now to
visualize um and start to look at the
neighborhoods that are emerging and
similarities between people so now we
have folks like uh Joy Baker DDS we have
so many dentists now and uh Jamie Castro
here um they're very close together like
they're being pulled together by a
number of different Pieces by
programming language by a time zone
right um and by their their location um
we want to be able to take this which is
a little bit difficult to look at to be
honest um and make it more customizable
so how do we take the uh the visual
pleasing piece but then also make it
interactive but also make it available
for someone who might not have the uh
Tech skills to use a notebook like this
um because basically what I have to do
is come in here and like change I want
to color by a different value like
instead of it being team let's make City
and then run this and then you know look
at the different pieces and and reassess
right uh so we can build this out into
an interactive application as
well so if we're already using plotly
which is great um associated with plotly
is another Library called Dash and so
what Dash is is it's a I mean it
actually doesn't need to use plotly at
all um but it uses flask as a web server
and generat react code and uh it will
serve that for you um in order to make
very uh potentially complex and pleasing
web applications only using python um so
here's a very simple example of how we
can uh make this available for users and
make it interactive um so here we can
like create our Dash object import some
stuff from Dash um we create a layout
which is the wireframe for the
application uh so here I'm like
um this all comes back to like very weak
wrappings loose wrappings around actual
HTML so um it's just Python and HTML and
so uh here we set um we have like a big
div that everything's in there's a
header it's going to say something
there's a paragraph here with something
in it and there's a button buttons are
great uh we can also Define a callback
and so this is the way of adding
interactivity to the application I'll
show you it in just a second um and so
in the call back we say when the button
and the the attribute of button which is
number of clicks is changing um run this
function and the return from the
function should uh be put into this
which is in this case it's this thing
the ID of title so it's this H1 header
on the top of the page uh and its
children there's what's contained within
it so I want to replace its children
with the uh result of this function
right um I'm going to really quickly uh
switch to light theme I'm sorry for
blinding everyone uh so yeah we have
this simple app this is running uh in an
iframe um inside of the notebook but it
actually can run as a normal application
like I mentioned it's a flask app um so
this is my app and I can click a button
and it does something right fantastic
this is going to be the Cornerstone of
everything we need to do uh to make this
app a bit more available um this is a
more complicated version which
introduces bootstrap to prove that it
can be um a little bit prettier um I'm
not going to go through it too much um
if you're interested check it out I know
if I have to start
oh I forgot to okay in order that seems
fire seems great so now we have a dark
theme application we chose the theme
from available themes in bootstrap uh
and this is going to have a couple
different inputs so here we're choosing
the number of paragraphs it's generating
and we can choose like a color for the
paragraph really just meant to be
indicative of how to customize these
pieces as you're going um the last piece
we have to do is we want to be able to
generate our graph for people um so
let's load in all that graph logic that
we have um and if we looked at the the
like sample app that we want to make
oops we don't like
that I was hoping it was just going to
work the second time uh it clearly
didn't um yeah we don't need to debug
this live that's fine
um so there's a couple ways that we can
simplify generating the things that we
need to generate um basically we need
something that takes our data whatever
form it's in and it makes the graph
object for us um the graph object should
have um like this should look familiar
we've kind of been building this up
throughout the process but we're making
a
graph we're adding the nodes from all
the people in our data frame so this is
taking the data frame turning into a
graph graph then we need the next step
which is we need to go through each of
the attributes that we want to highlight
in the graph and only add those in so
this is going to be one of our like
drop- down interactive elements when
we're building our app out um that's
going to let us explore this a little
more
so um we go through and uh we add the
attributes given in this list right so
now we can uh pretty easily uh call
that um and we add the edges and the
nodes from them right um the last piece
is we need to take uh our Network X
graph that we just have now and put into
a format that we can plot with Dash so
Dash has a couple ways to do this but uh
the most um I don't know well supported
way is with another JavaScript library
called cytoscape that does graph
visualization um we could actually have
used that the whole way as well but
there's no uh like interactive python
wrapper for it um which is fine um
great
great um so what we need to do is create
elements from it um luckily enough
Network X um provides a function to do
that we can just pass in our graph and
it will dump out to us um a format that
we can pass into cytoscape great so we
do that for the nodes and we do that for
the edges uh and then we can create our
graph and return the edge uh elements in
it um which is going to be just like a
big dictionary in the right format for
it um we can also play around with a
cytoscape allows you to style things uh
based on attributes that are inside of
the nodes um so this is how we're doing
that same thing with like coloring nodes
based on a certain attribute right um
and the way it wants it is with a a
little like a it has its own selector
language um which does some like pattern
matching based on values that are inside
of the nodes or the edges um so here
we're saying like all nodes should be
light gray with this font size and then
somewhere down here we're saying like
any Edge that has the label
apps
um yeah any uh node that has the edge
that has the label apps uh should have
this label on it um great so we can do
that and dynamically generate that and
uh style that for app and then really
the the last pieces are just uh plugging
in uh the drop downs or interactive
elements um that we already have
functions to generate and giving that
control to the user uh um and the app
itself is pretty simple we have our
little cytoscape thing we have a div
there's a bunch of nonsense that we put
in here about uh having links to
different things but uh a lot of the
the key stuff is like in this drop down
so we Define some different dropdowns
with different
options and then uh that's going to pump
through the app um and then our our
callbacks themselves we just whenever
someone changes which attributes they
want to um want to visualize uh we
create the elements for those attributes
and whenever they update the color and
the way they want to color we change the
stylesheet and we can run that and uh
we're happy with that um so if you've uh
sort of like uh if you checked it out
before um what this is when it's in
action is a our interactive plot here
we're looking at our data we can change
which values are being U rendered as
attributes I can keep removing things
and just uh divide people up in
different ways and potentially this is
something that we could give to uh
people who are new in starting we can
customize and build from this
point awesome so I know we're we're
basically at the end of time now um
thanks for stopping by uh thanks for
following along uh if anyone has
questions um and we have time for
questions I'm not sure if we do um happy
to answer some of them uh happy to do
that uh after time as
well
hey sorry I might have accidentally
muted you yeah we probably have time for
like a question or two uh considering
this is the last uh session of the track
so luckily we can do that um but yeah we
probably got one minute
left great I think I'm
back um yeah there's a couple questions
in the Q&A um I can kind of just like
rapid fire go through them
um oh is this how this
works uh is there a referal of thumb for
what network library to use uh based on
the number of nodes and edges yeah so
Network X can do anything that fits into
memory um you know your mileage will
vary with that but uh I use it as a
standard for everything getting started
I've never run into a big issue with it
if you're starting to work with massive
massive data with a lot of connectivity
and and information in it you'll need an
entirely different approach to things so
like you can think of things like
another very popular one is Neo forj
right but You' need to use like a the
Enterprise version that has sharding and
distributed compute involved another
approach in the open source World though
is uh like spark has um distributed
graph representations as well so you can
use spark and some distributed libraries
like that as well uh to represent your
data think gets really really big uh um
awesome
um yeah apologies I didn't see a lot of
the questions until now but some of
these might be old uh when you're
looking at creating Flags does this mean
all nodes are of a type node essentially
with a name of the type of the node it
is or will it actually create a country
node uh yeah so this is um this is
referring to like how we're creating
those uh flags on the nodes it's they're
not necessarily Associated and that's a
little bit of the art of like how we set
all of this up um is just adding another
attribute to that node and then later on
we can filter by that attribute or treat
those nodes differently based on whether
or not they have them so this is just a
a method that we have in order to keep
them separate logically as we're uh
building this out good question
um great uh skip to someone different
here uh any comments if there is any
potential of graph neural Nets in
solving this problem 100% definitely way
too complic for us to talk about uh on
top of this uh with all the other pieces
but uh yeah um there's lots of ways to
solve this specific problem another
really common way to do this without
just visualizing and looking at the data
which is you know we we're putting a lot
in the hands of somebody like um yeah
some
somebody knowing what they're doing and
like using this correctly but
um anyways long story short a really
common way to solve this is to take the
graph that we've created because it's
powerful and then make a node uh sorry a
vector representation of it usually
using something like node Toc um which
is a library to take these nodes and
then cast them into a higher dimensional
Vector space and then a lot of the more
modern AI ml um algorithms actually work
in Vector spaces already right and so
you're handing it something that's
already in there and you're asking it to
do things like build
clusters or like find nearest neighbors
and like those algorithms are really a
lot easier to execute that space so
that's kind of like what we're doing
visually like trying to like look for
clusters and you absolutely can do that
um programmatically and and with a
number of different uh methods
nice um great um there's a couple more
questions I think we answered in the in
the course of going through the notebook
but um yeah thanks again everybody for
tuning in and for coming out um one more
question popped up and the question is
just thank you so thank you and yeah
it's been great